see that ladder over there that ladder
motivated me to make this video because
no one should have to go through what I
did to find it because breaking the
bridge doesn't work finding your one
character with the cat ring to survive
the fall doesn't work but what does work
is killing this crawling tree once it's
dead you'll hear an audio cue which
signifies a ladder has spawned and it's
easy to miss it because who would think
to go back up here at the top of ladder
smith Gilligan's web dream is a type
night slab one of the three in the DLC
another place that looks out of reach is
the Coliseum structure which looks an
awful lot like the place we fought
Priscilla in Dark Souls 1 it's accessed
after breaking an illusory wall in the
lower part of the cave with the Flies
once you navigate the routes down you
get led to an invasion by livid
Pyromancer tunnel provided you've used
an ember and apparently every painted
world has its Pyromancer because the
corpse you get the parting flame from is
also the same one that gives you
Jeremiah's robes in Dark Souls 1 it
reads when Dunnell lost his hideous
spouse he gave his own pyromancy flame
as an offering which transformed into a
parting flame
not long after Donal became a mad spirit
and to wander the lands once you're done
fighting Pyromancer Donal just plunged
down from the plank and hurry home don't
worry it's totally safe the parting
flame has a really interesting webinar
you release your store of death echoes
to gain a modest dose of Estus or not so
to get this to trigger you need to keep
it in an active equip slot then build
enough death that goes for you to cast
it so this translates to killing about
twelve enemies for one charge of Estus
at a time
let's talk dialogue this stuff is really
interesting because the DLC adds a new
way to trigger dialogue you just have to
return to a place or character for the
second time
after reloading the level this is one
example the worst example it's a
seemingly pointless event where you get
to hear from the core vien down in his
cave mine flurry Oh far more interesting
is this piece of dialogue that triggers
the second time you approach the
white-haired woman after you've led her
out of the archive attic those who
aren't
kenta fire cannot paint a world those
absorbed by fire must not paint a world
don't worry I haven't forgotten another
so I'd say she fits the first line right
she's someone who isn't Kemper fire and
cannot yet paint a world re and L who's
the restorer of the painted world he
fits the second line as he's absorbed by
fire and perhaps shouldn't have painted
the world and as for the third line it's
trying to get us to ask a question who
is the white haired girl's mother is it
the woman depicted in the statues
holding a small girl perhaps or is it
Priscilla we'll talk about that a bit
later maybe the mother is related to the
girl's uncle Gale as well this man who
prays to the merciful goddess mother
after for long but time will tell more
about this character hopefully
especially considering how much of a
tease have final piece of dialogue is
this triggers the second time you talk
to her after killing the boss my thanks
ashen one I can almost see the flame
soon uncle Gale will bring me the
pigment
I wonder if he has found it the Dark
Soul of man it's almost like Gale is
still out there and that he's looking
for the Dark Soul of man the girl wishes
to paint upon her canvas so we'll have
to go more into what this means in the
lore video but before we go I just want
to say do you think pigment is a play on
words for pigmy the furtive pygmy was
the one who found the Dark Soul which
split into humanity after all maybe I'm
looking to father number 8 the crew like
corvin
also has final dialogue after you set
fire to the painting Oh My thank you
I can hear the crackling from here the
sound of my home the painting of a tin
Dell burning away when the world rots
and we set it afire for the sake of the
next world it's the one thing we do
right unlike those fools on the outside
[Music]
so this tells us of the psychical nature
of the painting this world that mirrors
the outside in a way you also get a slab
for your FS here so because the game was
updated my camera mods don't really work
well right now so it's hard to get close
up to some of these models but it's
worth talking about what some things
look like close up to give us clues that
we couldn't glean from just dialogue and
descriptions so this white haired girl
is the best example I might start
calling her aria not the white haired
girl and I call her aria because the
painters
so far have been Aria mist and Ariane
del Sol presumably
her name would take after theirs as well
white haired girl is just getting so
annoying to say so Aria she has scales
visible on her ankles and her neck and
also her eyes are a dark red and slitted
like reptiles Priscilla and vari are
myths
as the same sort of scales and the same
sort of eyes though hers are green so
considering this dialogue cotton it
might be that Arya's mother is Priscilla
given the similar scales and the eyes
and the hair so Priscilla is definitely
a promising candidate but we'll talk
more about this in her law video so next
let's talk about the environment in a
bit of detail just like we did the
models so in particular I want to talk
about three things
there's the snake statue at the end of
the boss chamber
there's the glass mural on the sides of
arendelle's chamber before he destroys
them and there's the intertwined
serpents upon the door of the church but
first let's talk about the snake statue
because you come face-to-face with this
thing immediately after the boss fight
and it's so deliberately placed and
designed that they want you to ask
questions about this thing your
attention is inevitably drawn towards it
so it's a statue because the face is
textured like wood and the scales on the
tail are torn and maybe rotting away
revealing that it's actually cloth
because you can see the thread between
them and since this cloth these scales
are rotting away you can actually see
inside the tail which reveals that it's
actually metal or wood segments
cylindrical segments held together by
wiring of some sort and they call it a
tail but really it's more like her lower
half hell it's more like her entire body
her torso is scaled like the tail is and
it's not really like a hood because if
the head piece hadn't worn away at the
front we'd be calling this thing a snake
straight up
we wouldn't be calling it a human it
would be entirely covered the shawl
around this thing's shoulders is like
fur and it reminds me of Priscilla's fur
so what is this thing and what does it
represent I don't know and I think
anyone can really claim to know for sure
but I think it could be a representation
of Priscilla but that's a stretch and I
think it also could be someone else
entirely and I got a lot of tweets about
this statue but I didn't get a single
one about the glass murals on the panels
during phase one of the boss fight
look at this it's creepy too dark women
Lee figures lean over a valley between
two darkly wooded cliffs one of these
women is resting upon a sword or a staff
and the other one is reaching down to
grasp a broken white cord at the bottom
below are the barely visible figures of
people reaching up towards them like a
lot of hollows do in the game when they
pray why isn't talking about this if I
had to guess I would say that maybe
they're the two other sisters of the
sable church of the wand or El Frieda
being the third the broken link could
represent how the sisters are seeking to
usurp the linking of the fire and the
figures at the bottom could be hollows
worshipping them that's the best theory
I got but what are your thoughts
lastly engraved upon the door of the
church are two snakes entwined it
reminds me of calf and trapped
Carthon frampt represent two sides of a
cycle one light one dark but both
irreversibly intertwined and doomed to
repeat so I'd say that's what it meant
to represent but I don't know why it's
here in the painted world but that's
enough floor talk let's talk about
something very insignificant which is
the crabs
I killed them so you don't have to one
drops a crystal gem Wow
number 12 the wolf you fight on the way
through the snow fields so in case you
ran past him and didn't kill him the
wolf gives titanite if you defeat him in
the snow field in both spots number 13
very interesting if you chose the lord
of hollows paths and ending in the base
game then Frida and Vilhelm formerly of
the say
Church which is related to that ending
have heard of you and when you talk to
them they beseech you to return to your
subjects to your hollows instead of
remaining in their painted world thou
art the Lord of London and half thine
own subjects to guide yuria has
something new to say as well
I sent seemeth most familiar a sweet
fragrance long faded from our own bosoms
my lord how this came to pass I know not
but take heed kindness can wear upon
one's principles and she has more
dialogue when you kill well Freda
towards the soul of my sister Belle
Freida a poor wench turned to ash who
would abandon wonder if thou wouldst let
it nourish the lordship and in return do
her once more more kindness remember
those who stayed by her to the end in
the shadows cast by fire and lastly my
lord take up my rightful mantle of
usurper so the number 14 a couple of
people on reddit have pointed out a nice
detail about the name elf Freda and the
change of the name to Freda so as we
know Ella Freda was a member of the
sable church and both urea and Vilhelm
refer to her by that name but she
renounced her past life and she found a
new purpose in the painting and here in
item descriptions and dialogue she's
known as sister Freda without the L at
the start and both of these names have
meanings that line up with who she was
at each time in her life so l Freda
according to Wikipedia means elf
strength and when she had that name it's
at a point where strength was a much
bigger part in
life the three sisters of the sable
church were known as very able sword
masters and they were known to be strong
enough to found the church just between
the three of them so Alfreda means
strength and Freda however is derived
from a Germanic element freed which
means peace and in the painted world
described as a peaceful land it makes
sense that she would change her name to
Freda for she found a people to care for
and even attempt to calmly reason with
you to leave the painting she doesn't
want to fight but she knows she'll have
to to keep the peace so froms naming was
really on point with this character and
finally for number 15 don't kill any NPC
in the painted world it's really not
worth it this time around you don't get
any exciting weapons or anything like
that
vilhelm and Freda disappear the crow
like corvin drops nothing Arya cannot
die for she says she has a world to
paint and Gale killing Gail I think
locked my soul level 135 character out
of the painted world forever because I
can't get him to appear I guess I'll
have to take this character to New Game+
now which kind of sucks so thanks for
watching guys hope you enjoy the re and
L content to come and let me know if
there's something I missed down in the
comments and go down in the comments and
see if there's anything cool down there
that people have posted about but thank
you for watching and I'll see you next
time